all across the Iron Islands men sit
around three foot fires and drink to the
old way when the Ironborn were feared
wherever the waves were heard when our
strength was in our ships not our
stories I don't blame them drinking to
the old ways easier than living it our
ancestors took to the sea because the
Iron Islands [ __ ] without the crops that
grow from it 30 coal wet rocks of the
coast of rest of us and a dozen more
clustered around the lonely light deep
in the sunset sea but hard places breed
hard men the first men feared the sea
they had walked to Westeros and even
their fishermen never left side of Shore
I wish I could have seen the face of the
first watchman to see our ships climb
over the horizon he was not the last no
matter how dark the night or how high
the waves come dawn our brows cut
through the morning mist and struck the
beaches and riverbanks before the Sun
reaches height we vanished again into
the sea our long ships filled with gold
food scared children and sobbing women
for thousands of years the Ironborn read
up and down the sunset see driving the
men of the green lands far inland or
into all castles where they paid us
tribute in the death of winter we
feasted while the men who had planted
and harvested crops top as sons worked
our minds and their daughters warmed our
beds the stories claimed that the old
way died would heard the black and his
sons at Harrenhal our ships and axis
when home match for air guns dragons so
our ancestors spend their steel in two
fishhooks and our kingdom in two
villages and started telling the red
tails around the fire of how we used to
be strong and how one they would be so
again generations later a young boy
listening to the Dalton Greyjoy the wild
young heir to Pyke was rowing at five
and reeving at 10 in the basilisk Isles
with his uncle by 14 Dalton had sailed
as far as old geese thought in a dozen
battles and claimed four soft wives in
his 15th year he advanced his uncle's
death in battle but he took a dozen
boons and emerge from the fight drench
head to healing blood
from that day forth men called him the
red cracker during the dance of dragons
the red kraken picked the side that was
fighting the Lannisters and fell upon
the westerland's while the Lannisters
were up at war Casterly Rock itself
proved too strong once the lady of the
castle barred its gates but the Ironborn
burned the Lannister fleet and sacked
Lannisport
carrying off gold grain and hundreds of
women and girls including Lord
Lannister's favorite mistress and all
his bastards the red cracker now ruled
the sunset sea as his forebears had and
his long ships again brought the old way
to the coast of Westeros but then the
war ended and the mainland armies came
home the Iron Throne commanded the red
kraken to stop breathing and when he did
each a mistress opened his throat as he
slept while his son squabbled the
Lannisters send their soldiers to the
Iron Islands thousands of men women and
children were put to the sword and
scores of villages and hundreds of long
ships were put to the torch the glorious
return to the old way had lasted almost
two years
my brother vowed to return us to the old
way as well he sat and salt throne and
sent our rivers to the shores of
Westeros just as he remembered from the
stories he heard as a child an old way
for an old man but while he listened to
the stories I lived
it was never the old way to me it was
the only way